das ist wirklich nicht gut das
grundwasser gibt zur neige das sagt eine
neue studie demnach sinken durch lange
dürreperioden wie hier in europa im
letzten sommer die grundwasserspiegel
unwiederbringlich die nächste absolute
katastrophe und die politik versagt die
selbstgesteckten klimaziele werden in
deutschland verfehlt danke liebe politik
ihr habt wirklich versagt und aber danke
an alle junge menschen die freitags auf
die straße gehen und sich das nicht
gefallen lassen klicks um
science-fiction wir unterstützen jede
aktion gegen den klimawandel macht mit
eure kinder werden euch fragen was ihr
dagegen getan habt herzlich willkommen
wir haben es geschafft damals als ich
zur schule gegangen bin haben wir
gestreikt vier wochen lang die ganze
schule und wir haben es geschafft damals
ging es um die langsame vergiftung der
ganzen schule und unsere direktorin ließ
es zu konkret in der ganzen schule waren
formaldehyd haltige deckenplatten
verbaut worden die folgen nasenbluten
kopfschmerzen und mögliche
langzeitschäden wie zum beispiel durch
krebs ich selber hatte immer
kopfschmerzen und ein sehr seltsames
trockenes nasenbluten im büro der
direktoren waren die deckenplatten
allerdings aus gebohrt worden ein schelm
wer böses dabei denkt aber für uns
schüler war es einfach nicht gut in
dieser schule zu sein also haben wir
gehandelt und gestreut vier wochen lang
und danach hat der damalige kölner
oberstadtdirektor endlich gehandelt und
die platten ausbauen lassen wir hatten
gewonnen und ehrlich gesagt habe ich
dabei mehr gelernt als während des
unterrichts und es ist wieder zeit dafür
unsere gesellschaft lebt auf kosten der
jungen generation und das ist wirklich
beschämend die neueste hiobsbotschaft
der grundwasserspiegel sinkt
unaufhaltsam eine studie einer
internationalen forschungsgruppe kommt
zu einem ernüchternden ergebnis weltweit
werden sich die hälfte der
grundwasserreservoirs nicht mehr
auffüllen es wird einfach mehr wasser
verbraucht als nach fließt im iran hat
sich das letztes jahr durch dramatischen
wassermangel gezeigt der schließlich zu
lokalen volksaufständen geführt hatte im
iran sind 97 prozent des landes von an
trockenheit damals betroffen gewesen in
mehreren städten gab es einfach kein
trinkwasser mehr die bevölkerung
protestiert dagegen sollen bei
auseinandersetzungen mit der polizei
demonstranten erschossen worden seien
angeblich sei ein rohrbruch schuld doch
der iran leidet unter einem fehler im
system hervorgerufen durch den
klimawandel
die temperaturen stiegen hier bereits
doppelt so stark wie im durchschnitt auf
der erde um bis zu zwei grad der
wasserverbrauch ist dabei immens die
vereinten nationen empfehlen 20 prozent
der wassermenge zu verbrauchen
die durch regen wieder aufgefüllt wird
im iran sind es achtung 110
dem land geht einfach das wasser aus es
wird wohl nicht mehr vermeidbar sein
dass zwölf von 31 provinzen in naher
zukunft unbewohnbar werden die folgen
durst hunger revolten und damit die
instabilität der ganzen region flucht
nach europa und selbst regen und selbst
hier in europa hilft da oft nicht mehr
wenn er in sturzfluten auf uns nieder
prasselt das wasser landet dann nicht
mehr in den grundwasserreserven sondern
fließt einfach ab 2016 war der
trockenste sommer seit 1963 und 2018
der heißeste sommer seit beginn der
wetteraufzeichnungen 1881 in deutschland
und wir werden von diesen entwicklungen
nicht verschont das forschungsteam
wertete jetzt grundwasser daten aus und
es stieß auf eine zeitbombe in den
kommenden 100 jahren werden die hälfte
aller grundwasservorkommen nicht mehr
aufgefüllt wir müssen etwas tun und
deshalb erstmal respekt an jede und
jeden der freitags streikt und auf die
straße geht jeder sollte alles tun was
in seiner macht steht um etwas zu
verändern deshalb macht weiter und ich
werde euch von hier aus unterstützt ein
riesenproblem ist ja auch der weltweite
plastikabfall helft mir bitte dabei
dagegen etwas zu tun und folgt und
verbreitet den instagram account get rid
of plastics werdet plastik los auf
deutsch dafür unbedingt hier
draufklicken und bitte darauf klicken
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran